blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman welcome to the show it's great to
be back uh i know i'm tan please no
emails about me being tan i wore
sunscreen i did all of it um we had a
lot of major major news events during
the period that i was gone uh farron and
jesse did a really great job of staying
on top of everything for you and i want
to start today
with the most requested segment over the
last 72 hours which was people coming to
me and saying david sir
please tell us what you think about
what's going on in afghanistan now as
many of you who have been with the show
for a while may remember you may not but
you may that we'll find out soon
you might remember that i talked about
the afghanistan withdrawal when donald
trump planned to do it and announced
that he was doing it
and i talked about it again when joe
biden announced hey that pause we put on
trump's afghanistan withdrawal we've
evaluated it and we are going to do it
and it's going to happen by september
11th
president joe biden is now being widely
criticized for his actions in
afghanistan which are carrying out the
plan to remove troops that donald trump
and republicans
bragged about and cheered for
for months during the end of donald
trump's presidency now that's not me
starting to say well i'm going to blame
here or there it's just the reality what
biden did was to go forward with more or
less the plan that donald trump
announced than that trump cheered
and that trumpists cheered predictably
just like we said a few months ago
whether it was trump leaving or biden
leaving it would cause chaos
but at a certain point our
responsibility has to end
because our involvement has been a
disaster staying longer won't solve
anything the afghanistan intervention
failed and it's really important in
these cases when people start saying oh
we left the wrong way or we did oh we
can talk about that
but at a certain point our involvement
had to end even though uh biden is
sending six thousand troops back in now
which we'll get to uh and it was going
to be a fiasco whenever it ended those
things were essentially uh uh
they were certain regardless of which
president was in the oval office when
this happened so we could stay and keep
failing or we could leave the vacuum
when we left as was worldwide news
earlier this week
immediately led to the taliban taking
over
and then all sorts of different hot
takes joe biden left the wrong way
we do have to ensure the safety of our
people and to be empathetic when it
comes to refugees that
we i am on board by saying
there should have been better advance
uh action
to prevent some of what we saw there
but unfortunately
a lot of it was essentially inevitable
as we said months ago
the same people
pro-trump republicans who now are
ignoring that donald trump had the same
plan
are starting to say this would have been
totally different if it had been managed
by a different president actually no it
wouldn't have been
and there are some trumpists as well as
people on the left who just don't like
joe biden who are now saying well the
vacuum allowed the taliban to take over
and we didn't do enough to get our
people
other people refugees out in time if we
had done the get people out in time part
you think those people would be
satisfied no those very same people
would just be focusing on the taliban
took over and we would be seeing the
exact same reactions from those people
and sadly there are tons of bad faith
actors on both sides on this issue now
i'm not saying the same number of people
on both sides i would be called out for
playing the both sides game if i did
that but there are bad faith actors on
both sides right now you have people on
the right saying terrible decision by
joe biden when trump was going to do
this
uh it was going to be totally different
no trump would have done it in the exact
same way don't let them lie and say
trump had some master plan for
preventing what happened trump had no
master plan for anything the idea that
he would he would have had such a plan
for afghanistan is absolutely absurd
trump would have done the exact same
thing and by the way
all the references to this being trump's
plan all along suddenly removed from the
gop website uh trump's websites within
hours of this going down in afghanistan
all of those references to trump's plan
to get out of afghanistan deal with the
taliban etc it's a bold-faced attempt
to revise history
then
the left saying this is the typical
centrist democrat foreign policy of joe
biden you go in for the wrong reasons
and then you cut and run well hold on a
second george w bush is responsible for
us being there not joe biden not donald
trump and not barack obama there is not
nearly enough discussion of george w
bush here and i think that you know if
you go to a bad dentist and the dentist
screws up your tooth
and then you go to other dentists and
the first dentist that tries to fix it
doesn't do a great job and then you go
to a third dentist and that dentist
basically gets you out of harm's way
you're not gonna have an abscess but the
tooth is gonna hurt for several months
we talk about what the third dentist
wasn't able to do we talk about how the
second dentist messed up the repair but
what started it was that first dentist
who messed up your tooth and there is
not nearly enough discussion to use a
dental analogy
of george w bush in the bush
administration's role here there's a lot
of biden versus trump stuff at some
point someone had to say
what george w bush started can go no
further
no more money into this
no more contractors getting rich the
contractor's mostly out of afghanistan
over recent months because the
withdrawal was coming
that with the contractors we've got to
stop that as well
uh and joe biden's speech to the nation
on monday it wasn't satisfying to a lot
of people who emailed me
but it was fundamentally an honest
speech and by honest i mean it's the
type of honesty we don't usually get
from politicians it was one of the most
honest political speeches by a president
in a long time and it was completely
decisive it was we had to do it
we had to do it as i tweeted earlier
this week quote so you stay another year
to leave correctly
simply delaying what happened by a year
enriching more contractors who would go
back in and so then what
the same thing happens in 2022
at some point you have to cut your
losses and joe biden's speech was
decisive and joe biden was the guy to do
it and he takes responsibility for what
took place after now if there's anything
to really criticize there it's well now
6 000 troops are going back in
to help people get out and
restabilize which we could say is going
backwards you pull out the last 1500
chaos ensues and you send the 6 000 back
in so i'm not saying
it's wrong to try to
help
grease the exit in some way i'm that
that's not my criticism but in in a
sense are we really even doing it if six
thousand are going back in well the
devil really is in the details with what
those six thousand are going to be doing
um and we will get back and we'll we'll
dig into that further
probably later this week but you know
what it had to be done you don't tend to
see this level of decisive action uh on
foreign policy combined with just
telling it like it is and so i think for
that you have to give biden credit and
then we figure out which aspects of it
could have been better managed i want to
talk to you today about republican
hypocrisy which has reached
heretofore unseen levels but this isn't
about one thing like okay you know we've
talked about vaccines and hypocrisy
before we had a decade where we talked
about gay marriage and hypocrisy from
the right this is a big picture issue
that if we can't pierce in some way
we may never make progress on some
really important issues that affect the
united states and the world this story
was actually inspired by a subreddit
user who goes by the name department
chair who posted about this a few days
ago on the subreddit really good post
and i realized this is something we
should be talking about right now and
really exposing
the uh feckless nature of what is
supposedly the right wing philosophy at
this point in time because republicans
claim to have at the center of their
political philosophy the principles of
non-intervention by government into
people's lives unless completely
necessary of not regulating business
unless
necessary of a smaller government that
does fewer things being a better
government all else being equal this has
been floating around in republican
circles
at least i mean popularized during the
reagan era although you could probably
find examples of it before then as well
now you and i we've seen this be utter
garbage at the micro level they say
small government but they want the
government to ban gay marriage what hold
on what that doesn't make sense they say
small government
but they want the government policing
cannabis at the state and federal level
that doesn't make sense but the reality
is that republican policy on endless
issues is incredibly interventionist
anti-libertarian
collectivist which they claim to be
against and in some cases it's even
oppressive to the degree that they want
to put policy in place and as our reddit
user department chair points out often
this is the case with victimless crimes
flag burning as an example same-sex
marriage
the pledge of allegiance in school so
just step back for a second and think
about all of the areas where republicans
self-professed
so-called small government conservatives
have demanded that government take
action over the last many decades i mean
okay abortion
decisions that should be made between a
patient and a doctor
for 50 years now ban it federally they
say ban it at the state level they say
regulate how many what procedures that
you have to have before an
abortion transvaginal ultrasound and on
and on and on regulate family planning
and they claim to be small government
conservatives that's been going on for
50 years for more than a decade it was
the government should ban
same-sex marriage that was a huge
political issue for more than a decade
the the
battle lines on gay rights have shifted
since the 2015 supreme court decision
but that was it for a decade ban
everything get the government involved
prevent teachers
from deciding what to teach ban the
teaching of critical race theory control
what teachers teach as if you know more
than they know the war on drugs
war on drugs
policing of drugs prosecution
incarceration
using it to justify surveillance war on
drugs alone is like 10 items that that
sort of follow from that
burning flags
something the supreme court has decided
is constitutionally protected speech
these republicans they want to ban it
they want to punish people a couple
months ago we did a segment where
i think it was at a trump rally an
interviewer was asking people what
should happen if somebody burns a flag
some republicans called for the death
penalty for burning a flag okay
surveillance an entire area in and of
itself now
i will say there are some libertarians
actual libertarians not just like
reactionary right-wingers who hide under
the name libertarian there are some
actual libertarians who are against uh
much of the the surveillance activity
that has been put in place by patriot
act nsa etc over the last decade more
but a lot of these right-wingers say no
no no we need that we need that in order
to find antifa we need that in order to
monitor muslims or whatever the case may
be okay
mandating the pledge of allegiance in
schools i mean you've got to be kidding
right no
no many can serve small government
government involved only when absolutely
necessary
requiring
wanting to require the pledge of
allegiance be recited in school and yet
they have the audacity
to mention government intrusion and
small government and freedom and liberty
when they come out against vaccination
requirements even by private businesses
when they come out against mass mandates
by municipalities or businesses and they
are even against private businesses
simply saying if you want to work here
you need a vaccine or if you want to
shop here you need a vaccine think of
that
they claim to want businesses to do to
be able to do whatever the hell they
want they say don't regulate business
business will decide what's best and the
market will punish them if they do the
wrong thing but they say oh no no make
it illegal for a businesses to require a
business to require an employee be
vaccinated make it illegal for a
business to require masks make it
illegal for a business to require
customers to show proof of vaccination
and why is it it's all so simple guys
it's because their principles are bs
they don't really have principles at
least not anymore
they are about whatever talking point
sounds good right now
and it gets us what we want right now
that's what we believe in
that's what we stand for until it's no
longer convenient and then they're
against that very thing their one
principle
is somehow
figure out a way to own the libs it's
truly one of the most bad faith
political movements i can think of and
you know you go back and you look at the
racist origins of the war on drugs in
reaction to the civil rights movement of
the late 50s early 60s you look at the
uh anti-welfare movement of the reagan
era and how racially tinged that was and
all all these different there was a lot
of bad faith going on but at this point
they're barely even pretending to have
principles even their principles like
you hear them and it's like come on dude
that's bs
you know you don't even believe that
because look at example one two three
four five six seven where you abandon
those principles because the outcome of
applying that principle would no longer
be the one you want so why do we care
about this we care about it
because since it has become
the orthodoxy of the republican party i
mean you want to see hypocrisy
mitch mcconnell on supreme court picks
right just just look it's the perfect
example of how this unbridled and
unpunished hypocrisy
gets them political wins and so if we
don't find a way to pierce this
i worry seriously that the left will
struggle to really make progress on some
major important issues let me know what
you think okay you can find me and
follow me on twitter at dpakman it's
great to be back we have a really big
show for you today i'll talk about my
vacation on the bonus show let me just
preview one aspect of the bonus show
today
positive
covered
test
that's all i'm going to say
on today's bonus show
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
all right let's get back into it it's
great to be back in the studio today i
do want to remind you not only is this
program mostly funded by memberships who
uh sign up at joinpakman.com members who
get memberships at joinpakman.com we did
do our 16th anniversary special on
monday if you missed it and you want the
discount code just email info
davidpakman.com today is a great day to
sign up why
i have a story from my vacation which i
will tell on today's bonus show which i
will summarize only as
positive
covered test
this is an incredible story okay on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
speaking of covid
persistent covid miss manager republican
texas governor greg abbott has tested
positive for the coronavirus he's
reportedly isolating and he is receiving
a monoclonal antibody treatment
according to his office now remember
that this is the same greg abbott who
wanted to block local officials from
mandating masks who wanted to open
everything who was part of the
administration whose lieutenant governor
dan patrick said
grandma will sacrifice herself for the
economy that was early in the pandemic
back in 2020. now you might be asking
why was abbott even tested uh given that
he is asymptomatic because he's
reportedly been tested daily and he
finally turned up positive for the first
time this week
they've also announced that everybody
abbott has been in contact with has been
notified now i really wonder whether
that's true
because that is a ton of people
look at these videos in the video i'm
playing for you now this is from the
last couple of days
you see greg abbott indoors he's uh the
one in the wheelchair in the middle of
the frame as the camera pans to the
right
without a mask
in a room with maybe a hundred people
without masks hugging taking pictures
shaking hands
that was monday night when he was
presumably already
positive for the virus his positive test
was yesterday
here's another video of abbott on
tuesday yesterday on stage at a big
republican event singing masculist we
know that singing is a major spread
activity uh this isn't a big crowd the
entire crowd is actually singing check
this out
[Music]
is
[Music]
okay so that that's that's uh probably
enough sorry for subjecting you to that
there
um so there is greg abbott uh presumably
coveted positive singing and then here
is abbott in a very cozy close-up
meeting with a supporter of some kind of
fan of his we might say masculist indoor
greeting at one of these events so how
many people did the republican governor
give the virus to
before he tested positive himself now he
will probably be fine
um he has the best medical care money
can buy your money by the way i mean tax
money
he's getting the antibody treatment
he's reportedly asymptomatic and think
about that for a second vaccinated and
no symptoms
and he still gets the expensive antibody
treatment these guys are truly horrible
zoom out and it's this dystopian big
picture they go around advocating for
not taking precautions
they say don't close anything
grandparents willing to die sacrifice
themselves for the economy
so they take no precautions
tons of people in their state get sick
and die
then they get an asymptomatic case and
immediately get the best treatment
available even one that would never go
to an asymptomatic vaccinated person and
they
at least what's thought to be a good
treatment and then they pretend that
that's proof that we don't really need
to worry about it look listen i got the
vaccine i didn't wear a mask i did my
thing i got the expensive monoclonal
antibodies and i came out fine so we
really don't need to worry about it even
though that's a treatment almost none of
us would get if we were to become sick
and he gets it all paid for by our taxes
some federal state etc
understand that this is not a minor
point
he's fully vaccinated
he's asymptomatic
he feels fine but he gets the monoclonal
antibody treatment anyway now the other
possibility and a few people wrote to me
saying you know david maybe it's not
that he's asymptomatic and getting the
antibody treatment maybe it's that
they're lying that he's asymptomatic
he's actually really sick but they're
gonna give him that treatment anyway i
just don't think so i mean unless he the
video of him around a ton of people is
from yesterday so unless he got like
really sick
late yesterday and they already are
putting him on the antibodies i just
don't think so i think that he's just
getting the treatment because he's the
governor of texas and by the way
you know just just as a little because
you hear from all these anti-vaxxers the
vaccine's not yet fully approved by the
fda sir
neither is the monoclonal antibody
treatment it's approved under this very
same type of emergency use authorization
that the vaccines are so tons of
anti-vaxxers it's funny because they say
that vaccine no no no that's not fully
approved by the fda plus we have a great
treatment if i did get it and i did get
really sick we've got the monoclonal
antibodies that's the same type of
emergency use authorization neither is
fully approved by the fda
so
absurd at the macro level
ridiculous at the micro level
feeds misinformation and some of these
governors seem determined to just keep
going going going
until such time that everybody in their
state has cobit and the first guy that
comes to mind when i think of that
is republican florida governor ron
desantis let's talk about him a little
bit next
what is going on in florida right now
with coronavirus
is so hellacious
it's so dreadful it's so vicious that if
we're not careful
republicans might make ron desantis
their 2024 republican presidential
nominee republicans seemingly obsessed
with choosing the worst people to be
their nominees and desantis is really
messing things up in florida let's take
a look at what's happening
florida started the pandemic not well
ron desantis very early saying closures
now open everything a wwe needs a place
for wrestling matches come to florida
ufc
wants to do fights come to florida bring
the cruise ships ban masks ban masks in
school on and on and on okay first of
all the case graph in florida
almost looks like a cartoon
since the end of july florida which is
just one of 50 states it represents just
6 percent of the country's population
florida regularly hitting 20 000 cases a
day
25 000 cases a day day after day after
day
even these numbers may be low because of
lack of testing i got a report yesterday
from a viewer in florida who said at
doctor's offices there can be a
five-hour wait to get a covered test
and then the only other types of testing
you can get
are the ones that you have to book days
in advance
and then you often don't get the results
for days either so it appears as though
at least anecdotally
the testing abili uh the testing
availability in florida is so dire
that the case counts are probably being
under counted okay it's it's
uh uh so
uh terrible in florida to get a test
that many people who should be getting
tested just aren't and we are getting an
under count by every every sense of the
data on the on the ground now you might
come in and you might say well hold on
but but but if the vaccine makes covid
not serious
then cases don't really matter since
people who are vaccinated and get
coveted don't really get sick right well
this is a florida explosion mostly
of the unvaccinated as we're seeing in
many states
florida's coveted hospitalizations have
hit
another record high now you might say
david right before you went on break
didn't you tell us florida's
hospitalizations hit a record high and i
did but it's a new record we've
surpassed that number
covered hospitalizations hitting you
high in florida a new report from the
florida hospital association showed 16
521 people hospitalized with the
coronavirus up 773
from the day before and 162 percent
higher than this time last year
now then you might say okay
hospitalizations but we're better at
treating it now what about deaths
florida has done something
i guess we can call it slick
it's really completely dishonest about
death reporting as you can see here
as all of this ramped up in florida
death started to skyrocket but when you
look at the death count if you look at
the chart we have on screen
a few days ago all of a sudden the
deaths dropped to almost zero how how
did they do it oh my god ron desantis
fixed covid
there's only there's almost no deaths in
florida anymore how do they do it record
cases
record hospitalizations and the deaths
drop to almost zero well they are lying
and what i mean by that is they are
being very deceptive in how they report
deaths they are reporting deaths in bulk
infrequently and on a delay
so when you look the latest days always
seem low it looks like there's been this
big decline
if you look at our chart after a bunch
of days with a hundred deaths a day 110
deaths a day 120 deaths a day suddenly
flora florida had 11 deaths on monday
only seven seven deaths yesterday how
could this be
the answer is these are not real numbers
in another week
they will come out and report the death
numbers for this week they will be high
the chart will be readjusted but then
again there will be blanks it'll be
almost zero for the dates next week that
are recent and it always looks like it's
a huge decline it's incredibly deceptive
because at any point a denier someone
who doesn't understand what florida is
doing with the death numbers they can
just pull up the data and say look
massive decline in deaths in florida
it's completely deceptive florida is on
covet fire
more than 5 000 students are now
quarantined or isolated
in just one school district we're seeing
pediatric icu cases in florida like we
haven't seen anywhere the entire
pandemic and this is after a very short
period of time
of schools reopening many of the
pediatric icu cases may not even have
been from in-school contagion yet so it
could get even worse in florida if you
can imagine and we're going to have more
coverage of the florida situation
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us at david pakman
show
if you want to know what i was up to for
the last 10 days follow my instagram at
david.pacman and we have a very
uh
if you want a vegetable break
i had a crazy backyard garden harvest
waiting for me when i got back from my
trip yesterday i posted a picture to my
instagram at david.pacman find it follow
me and we'll be back right after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right so i want to go over a couple
of these stories which have now become
all too common where some anti-vax
person some cova denier some
anti-faucist whatever
uh ends up getting sick and dying of
coronavirus and one of these stories i
know farin did while i was gone but i
want to give my take on and i think
there's there's quite a bit to say
these are not like fun happy stories
they're not funny stories
for me it's not i mean listen you guys
know i don't take pleasure in the death
of of folks who
just fell for for bad information
but we can't ignore the fact that
especially when they change their mind
on the vaccine once they get sick and
people hear that
it can be a cautionary tale and it may
actually have some impact in getting
getting more people to go ahead and get
vaccinated so let's start with the first
one
this is a story of h scott appley
a texas republican official
who mocked
the coveted pandemic
five days before
dying of the virus
okay
h scott aptly
the daily beast writes a republican
official from texas who regularly
espoused anti-vaccine anti-mask views
online
has died from covid19
five days after posting a meme
on facebook
questionating i'm sorry questionating
questioning the wisdom of getting
inoculated
against covid
dickinson city council member and state
republican executive committee member h
scott apley 45 years old not 65 plus not
75 85 the way many republicans like to
say 45 year old h scott appley
died in a local hospital
around 3 a.m wednesday morning
according to a gofundme page
set up to help his family with expenses
now i'm going to get to that in a moment
as well
he was admitted to the facility in
galveston on sunday with pneumonia-like
symptoms hooked up to a ventilator as
his condition worsened his wife was also
infected
um
texas republican party chairman matt
rinaldi said please join me in lifting
the aptly family up in prayer
see
instead of praying now what about
vaccinating before
is is that crazy is that a crazy
reaction to have now the prayer
of going on to say we will miss scott
deeply but find comfort
in knowing he's at peace in the arms of
our savior
you find comfort in that
what about the fact that he could have
been vaccinated and would have been very
unlikely to see this happen what about
that part the opposite of comfort is
what that should be
the announcement did not mention that
aptly's death was coveted related
appley is a staunch conservative and
devout christian
but based on his social media activity
aptly didn't believe kovid was going to
affect him or his family
in may aptly posted an invitation for a
mask burning being held at a bar in
cincinnati commenting i wish i lived in
the area a couple weeks earlier he
posted a news article about giveaways
and incentives meant to encourage people
to get vaccinated writing disgusting
aptly also railed against so-called
vaccine passports which restrict
high-risk activities such as indoor
dining to the fully vaccinated recently
he suggested mass mandates in germany
were akin to nazism
and when former baltimore health
commissioner leanna wen celebrated good
news about the pfizer vaccine efficacy a
seemingly outraged aptly called her an
absolute enemy of a free people you can
go it's all the same stuff in facebook
posts aptly wrote if businesses start
allowing customers and employees go mask
free only with voluntarily providing
their vaccination record presumably not
a hipaa misspelled violation
wouldn't that basically involuntary it's
we can't even understand a word this guy
was writing
what a mess
so listen what what are the takeaways
here
i'm not happy this guy died
but if his death serves to get some
anti-vaxxers vaccinated
it will not be totally in vain although
it is a senseless death which almost
certainly not a hundred percent but
almost certainly could have been
prevented with a vaccine so take away
number one
we have something the vaccine
which makes you really unlikely to get
super sick and die of covet now
there's data coming out about
breakthrough deaths right
we're learning that we're probably all
heading towards third doses we'll talk
about that tomorrow big announcement
expected probably today
we're learning that
efficacy wanes over time
but it's still a very powerful tool for
making you unlikely to be hospitalized
and die
that's takeaway number one
um now some people still will die right
like with flu
with colds sometimes
in a con you know in a planet of seven
billion people
things that don't normally cause a
problem statistically very small number
but still a percentage
will cause a problem and people will die
but most won't when they are vaccinated
it's the best tool we have in choosing
not to take advantage of it is absurd
now the gofundme page i mentioned that
they have a gofundme
they talk about personal responsibility
they choose not to get vaccinated
they still expect to be taken care of at
the hospital
and then they or their families beg for
money for health care
which almost certainly is not money they
would need
because they didn't get vaccinated had
they gotten vaccinated they probably
wouldn't need that money that is not
personal responsibility that is not
personal responsibility and that's
another aspect earlier in the show i
talked about you know the stated
principles for lots of these people
they're not deeply held beliefs they're
just what they think they can say now to
get what they want out of society or out
of a government or out of people in
their lives and the principles are
abandoned as soon as it's no longer
convenient for them let's now talk about
another one of these stories sadly
um
farron cousins during my break
talked about this and i want to talk a
little bit more about it
because this is now an actual
broadcaster
vocal anti-vaccine broadcaster dick
farrell
has died from covid 19 complications
okay this was uh about a week ago i was
away when it took place
friends say dick farrell encouraged them
to get the vaccine after he was infected
so this is out of florida
former south florida talk show host dick
farrell known and beloved by fans for
his over-the-top right-wing opinions
has died from complications from covet
19.
on facebook farrell advocated against
getting the coronavirus vaccine and was
skeptical of dr anthony fauci chief of
the u.s national okay nih
and his recommendations concerning the
coronavirus friends say after
contracting the virus he changed his
point of view
kovit took one of my best friends rest
in peace dick farrell he is the reason i
took the shot he texted me and told me
get it he told me this virus is no joke
and he said i wish i had gotten it
that's farrell's close friend amy lee
hare
on her facebook page she said to wptv i
was one of the people like him who just
didn't trust the vaccine i trusted my
immune system i just became more afraid
of getting coveted 19 than i was of any
possible side effects of the vaccine i'm
glad i got vaccinated
that's a good thing
um and you know when we talk about
senseless death
there's a lot of different things that
we could mean we could mean that it was
avoidable
that's one thing when we say senseless
death we could be this was easily
avoidable it made no sense
sometimes by senseless death we mean it
was a death that accomplished nothing so
if
the military is waging some battle that
is a pointless battle that win lose it's
relevant it doesn't do it helps no one
and then someone dies we would say it
was a senseless death because the death
didn't even contribute anything to a
worthwhile cause so senseless death can
mean a number of different things
if
we are going to have these anti-vaxxed
people
and some of them are going to die
are we better off if they are prominent
and have a platform and then it gets out
that hey this person that you might have
heard of this person you listen to they
now are saying get the vaccine does it
reduce the senselessness
of the death i think to some degree it
does
former market general manager for cbs
radio west palm beach lee strasser
remembers farrell he was flamboyant
outrageous willing to take on any and
all comers loved to engage with local
politicians pulled no point punches was
he right all the time no
but he was right all the time meaning
right wing especially if you asked him
did he stay out of trouble not always
was he great with clients yes was he a
pleasure in the building absolutely was
he loyal unquestionably was he skilled
yes sir his passing is a big loss
he was a kind hearted person
etc etc
so um
a straight-up anti-vaxxer a straight-up
anti-vaxxer now saying
go and get yourself the vaccine
this is not a problem that's going to go
away any time soon
and particularly i don't want to get
ahead of myself but particularly as it
looks like
at the eight month mark of your
vaccination it will be recommended to
get a third dose what the jnj vaccine
recipients will be instructed to do we
don't yet know but for those who got the
two dose vaccines pfizer or moderna with
a third dose likely coming
this is going to be
another opportunity to have
significantly more protection and
it's going to be another opportunity for
these people to go
they just want to keep vaccine and
vaccine in order to
control us or microchip or whatever the
case may be
so as bad as it's been unfortunately
when the third dose recommendations go
sort of widespread and that could be
anywhere in the next 24 to 48 hours
there will unfortunately be even more of
this that we're going to have to contend
with
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow right so as most of you
probably noticed while i was gone donald
trump wasn't reinstated joe biden is
still the president mike lindell was
wrong
uh q
you know whatever z why they they were
all wrong actually okay oh you guys get
it trump is not going to be reinstated
um the department of homeland security
is now actually increasingly worried
about the demands for violence they're
starting to see from trumpist circles
if donald trump is not reinstated now of
course you and i know trump is not going
to be reinstated and so that's very very
concerning there's a good rolling stone
article which we're going to look at by
peter wade
called die hard trump supporters
increasingly demand violence if he isn't
reinstated homeland security warns
the department of homeland security
issued a warning believers in the false
conspiracy theory that trump will be
reinstated have increased their calls
for violence if the former president
isn't back in the white house soon
some conspiracy theories associated with
reinstating former president trump have
included calls for violence if desired
outcomes are not realized the dhs
bulletin obtained by abc news said
the bulletin went on to say that the
recent increase in public visibility of
liars like the mypillow guy mike lindell
by the way check out his interview with
me from a couple weeks ago
is the reason for the uptick in violent
online chatter
lindell continues to relentlessly push
the big lie that the election was stolen
going so far as to say that he expects
the supreme court to unanimously rule in
favor of reinstating trump as president
in august that's a delusional belief
over the last few days what has occurred
is there's been much more public
visibility meaning the discussions and
these theories have migrated away from
being contained within the conspiracy
extremist online communities to where
there being the topic of discussion on
web forums or more public web forums
even within the sort of media ecosystem
that's according to a senior dhs
official
the drunk on trump crowd has been
triggered so much that homeland security
says they're concerned about the calls
for violence increasing further we have
been concerned about the exact same
thing
going on to say does this bulletin as
public visibility of the narrative's
increases were concerned about more
calls to violence past circumstances
have illustrated that calls for violence
could expand rapidly in the public
domain
and may be occurring outside of publicly
available channels as such lone
offenders and small groups of
individuals could mobilize to violence
with little to no warning
the dhs added although they do not have
specifics of an imminent threat their
reporting indicates the timing for these
activities may occur during august
although we lack information on specific
plots or planned actions so there's a
few different things here number one
donald trump is going back to the
rallies this saturday this saturday
in fact uh
i'm debating i'll tell you it's like
this this stuff is so base but i'll tell
you so there's trump's doing a rally in
alabama this saturday uh 8 p.m east
7 pm central i'll i'll be streaming it
there are some who believe that at this
rally
donald trump is going to call
for another insurrection and that all
hell is going to break loose that's one
hypothesis
the other
idea that's been floated
is that at the rally saturday
trump will be reinstated that's the the
it'll be in alabama because it's a good
southern state i guess who the hell
knows and trump will be reinstated on
saturday and there are
fears
that when he is obviously not reinstated
saturday um that some of the followers
will will take the violence um
immediately
i don't know what the hell is going on
so that's one piece of it and that's
part of the relevance of this this
particular week secondly
how low brow is it to have trump as a
hero
like what you know it's this is very
coarse right it's not this is not deep
politics but
the bizarre hair and the strange tan and
the idiocy he doesn't know anything
about history or economics or politics
hasn't read a book in his adult life
he's a billionaire but he can't even
even get suits that look even reasonably
okay
like he's just an embarrassing mess of a
person and you really have to understand
cults to understand what's going on it's
it's the jim jones stuff i go back to
the people's temple
um
uh road to jonestown check out jeff
guin's book it's a fantastic
it's instructive history really
about how these cult leader types end up
with the followers that they have so
dhs is worried
we've been worried and let's hope that
nothing like this happens this weekend
here's a really interesting question
if i ask you as a probably you know the
the who's the typical david pakman show
viewer just on average the david pakman
show viewer is
a college educated
often making more than 75 000 a year
mostly male as many of these shows are
vaccinated
individual okay the average david pakman
show viewer and of course there's people
of all kinds in the audience i'm just
giving you the demographic data we have
about how our audience skews the average
david pakman show viewer if you ask them
if i ask them i'll ask you right now
who is to blame
for the accelerated rise in covid that
we are seeing right now what what
individuals
most of you would say the people who
have chosen not to get vaccinated now of
course the delta variant is more
contagious we're still understanding
seasonality decreased waning efficacy of
the vaccine after the eight-month period
all these different things but obviously
if everybody was vaccinated by now we
wouldn't be seeing what we are seeing
right now in particular hospitalizations
and deaths now let me ask you a
different question
if i asked you
what or who would the average
unvaccinated person blame
for the spike in covid what would you
say
well there is a new
axios uh ipsos poll
and it is absolutely insane look at this
so i'm putting the graph up on the
screen i'm gonna explain it to everybody
okay
the answers in green are the answers of
vaccinated people whereas the answers in
red are the answers of unvaccinated
people so case in point you go to the
vaccinated and you say what's to blame
for the rise of covid and the new
variants 79
of the vaccinated say the unvaccinated
are to blame okay that's that's backed
up by science
uh the vaccinated also blame in
descending order donald trump
uh conservative media now they're not
saying trump is infecting people but
it's the vaccine hesitant and covet
isn't serious rhetoric of trump
conservative media doing the same thing
foreign travelers in the u.s americans
traveling internationally etc okay
the unvaccinated
they immediately gravitate to foreign
travelers in the u.s are the ones that
are to blame
and then they go to
mainstream media
is to blame
and in fourth place they have joe biden
is to blame
and then they have the cdc is to blame
and then they have national public
health officials are to blame this is a
completely backwards view
the and by the way
only 9.8 percent of the unvaccinated
blame themselves
for what is going on right now
this is a view which is based on
why why do we blame the cdc
and the national public health officials
well because they can't be trusted and
fouchy was wrong about masks in march of
2020 and they're spreading lies and gain
of function research and all of this
different stuff joe biden is to blame
joe biden has been trying to get people
vaccinated biden's to blame what what
are you talking about
um and then foreign travelers in the
united states seems to be the point of
agreement
right around you know 29 uh i'll put the
numbers back up on the board 29
of the vaccinated and 37 percent of the
unvaccinated say foreign travelers in
the us are to blame that's the one where
these numbers are uh relatively close
this is just a world view that is
totally disconnected from what the
science tells us so how do we deal with
this
these are not folks listen if you think
mainstream media is behind the explosion
of delta case infections
and hospitalizations and deaths
how are we going to be able to have an
even remotely substantive conversation
with you we're not going to be able to
so then what do we have to do
we probably have to do what some cities
and states or mostly cities are starting
to do you want to go to the movies you
got to be vaccinated
you want to go to a restaurant and sit
indoors you got to be vaccinated i'll
talk on the bonus show today about my my
trip
when i was in germany
um i went to a place that had like an
out it was like a beer garden german
beer garden had a big outdoor area and
an indoor area i went to the door
the waitress comes up and says if you
want to go inside i need to see
vaccination or a negative test from
today
um and it makes sense that that's what
you would start doing you've got to
start making it more annoying
not to be vaccinated because if you
think mainstream media is behind the
rising cases and not the fact that we've
only fully vaccinated roughly half the
country
um then it's going to be very hard to
convince you otherwise really really
difficult stuff and by the way speaking
of can't you just fake a vaccine card
yeah you can and that's actually the
topic of today's voicemail
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 davidp
you can call anytime i am slowly going
through the 600 voicemails i have from
when i was away um here is one that came
in about a guy whose friends
are going to
fake vaccine cards take a listen
hi david a big fan of your show
i just found out
very heartbreaking that
two of my friends that i was close with
they both plan on getting fake coven
vaccine cards
and i tried to report them to the local
department of health
i'm not sure if i'm doing enough though
um so if i could get any insight on this
i'm kind of shaking because i was so
upset when i found out this morning
it's a disgusting thing to be doing so
let's let's talk about a few things
first of all is requiring vaccination a
waste of time if you can fake a vaccine
card no
no system is foolproof no system is
foolproof but
it's so easy to get vaccinated i know
you'll say a lot of people don't want to
get vaccinated for political reasons and
i get that
but it's so easy to get vaccinated it's
really easy for for most people it's
easier to get vaccinated than to figure
out how to put together a vaccine card
that you feel really would pass muster
that the whole point is let's just use
that to convince more people to go and
get vaccinated no system is foolproof i
mean i'll be honest to get back to the
united states from europe
i needed a negative test within 72 hours
of coming back
um and i i did one i got one i brought a
test with me that i connect with someone
it's called a telehealth observation
they watch me do the test i put the
drops in the thing they verify that i
did it correctly it comes back negative
they send me a pdf
i could have faked the pdf i mean you
know at frankfurt airport
it was
five seconds that they looked at it and
really all they looked at was does it
say negative
um
does it say my name
and is the date within three days i
could have been showing anything at all
are some people probably faking the
negative tests yes but for enough people
it's difficult enough to know how do i
make a real you know a good-looking pdf
this that i'll just go and get myself
the test any system is going to have
some people that get around it no system
is foolproof i don't think that's a
reason not to do it now
um
what essentially is being done when you
fake a cdc
vaccination record
is
you were using an official government
agency's seal
um
without authorization and that's a crime
okay so when people do that
there may be law written
to specifically go for faking
vaccination
but faking a cdc certificate is a crime
it can be punishable under title 18 us
code section 1017 and other laws so it
is a crime so you should report it if
you know of people that are doing this
this is really it's an attack on
humanity really because what you're
doing is you're endangering people and
the recommendation is you call 1-800 hhs
tips
or
you can go to ic3.gov that's for
internet crime i don't know if it's
exactly an internet crime but that's
another recommendation so 1 800 hhs tips
or
ic3.gov you can also uh contact uh local
law enforcement you can contact your
local district attorney attorney almost
anyone should be able to direct you as
to what to do so not only should we make
it easier to just get vaccinated than to
fake a certificate
we should really be making examples out
of people that are caught faking the
certificates i've already read in fact
that because the card can be faked
that there's going to be a different
method and electronic record maybe or
whatever the case may be we're going to
have to wait and see all right
it's so great to be back we have a
fantastic bonus show uh producer pat
will defiantly and heroically rejoin me
on the award-winning world famous bonus
show i am going to talk to you about my
uh trip i'm going to talk to you about
positive coveted test i have a
story from my trip that i am calling
positive covet test
um and we will talk about so many other
things that are uh taking taking place
and things we missed during my break and
so on and so forth so get instant access
you go to joinpakman.com
you sign up
we did do a 16th anniversary special if
you missed the email and you want the
code
send an email to info davidpakman.com
you are not going to want to miss listen
i'll i'll give you i don't have coven
okay i don't have covert but i'm going
to give you a story that is crazy
involving a positive coveted test
over my trip so sign up at
joinpakman.com we'll speak to you then
we're here tomorrow i look forward to
taking some of your calls on the friday
show it's really great to be back
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 percent off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman